How did you all meet and how does this common experience of Hombu unite you?
I joined the Hombu in April, 1975.
There were a lot of French people like Tissier Sensei back then.
I came from the Kyushu region,
so I hadn't seen many foreigners,
and it was like wow, this is so different.
Also, I’d only practiced with Japanese people
and the practice with the foreigners was really tough for me because they were taller and stronger.
At the Hombu, I trained with Tissier Sensei under Kisshomaru Sensei for about a year,
until he returned to France in 1976.
Regarding Okamoto Sensei, I think she arrived when I was live-in [instructor],
she came from France...
[Okamoto Yoko] It was in 1978.
1978...
So that's definitely when I was living at Hombu.
[Okamoto Yoko] Yes, I started at Hombu.
I remember seeing her during Yamaguchi Sensei’s class.
Yes, around that time. It's only after that I went to France and came back.
Yes that's right.
I also remember Tissier Sensei training with a great variety of teachers,
starting with Kisshomaru Sensei from Monday to Sunday.
Yes, that's correct.
Yes, I don't have much to add to what he says but that's it.
Him and I met in 1975.
When he arrived from Kyushu, he had already some ranks.
He was very "lively" during practice.
I had a lot of pleasure practicing with him.
It was often a bit intense,
but those were the times.
Miyamoto Sensei, Shibata Sensei, Seki Sensei, Iwagaki Sensei, were there.
It was a very solid group.
I had a lot of pleasure training with them.
We had technique and we were young
so there was a sort of emulation between us.
For Yoko, it's a little bit different because we met before she started Aikido.
She studied French so we had some friends common.
It's along story.
She started Aikido after I left but we then met again in Paris.
She attended my dojo for a few years.
That is how life is.
In life, there are lots of opportunities to meet people.
Some are more important than others.
Some aren't important at the time while others are.
We can't foresee how things will turn out
but in the end, there is something that unites us, even though we don't know what it is.
At some point, it emerges again.
I have had that experience with many people.
We have something in common, but we can't define it.
For us, it could be our love for Aikido.
But with people like Miyamoto Sensei and Yoko, I think it is more of a heart connection.
On my part, I like the man.
I like what Yoko represents,
especially in a Japanese environment.
It must be difficult for her.
Things are difficult for women in Europe too, but here, it is even harder.
She's someone who found her place
and people give here that place because it's hers.
Miyamoto Sensei is very humble,
and very engaged in Aikido.
(I don't want to take too much time)
I think that what unites us even more among some Shihan
is our loyalty to the Ueshiba family.
I think that if Kisshomaru was still with us today,
he would be happy.
He would be happy to see that youngsters that he knew in their late teens
are still doing things together well into their 60's --67 for me---
with respect, joy, and, I hope, quality.
I started in 1978,
so that was about three years after Miyamoto Sensei came here.
Christian was already gone by the time I started,
but I went to his dojo for practice when I left for France to learn the language.
To go back to Guillaume’s question about what connects the three of us together,
of course, it is definitely like Christian said: our passion for Aikido, but there is more.
When I started, Miyamoto Sensei was an uchi deshi.
Miyamoto Sensei, Yokota Sensei, and Osawa Sensei were all uchi deshi.
They were considered the top three, the top three uchi deshi and we never dared to approach them. [laughs]
They are the ones who taught me everything.
And when I went to France, Christian taught me everything he learned at the Hombu Dojo.
We, the three generations including me, Christian, and Miyamoto Sensei,
attended practice sessions from every teacher there was,
and of course that of Doshu,
and it was completely different each day.
We all learned Aikido by learning from all the different teachers and I think that is what connects us.
Of course we all had our favorite teachers,
as a human tendency, but we were all on the same boat called the Hombu,
as a human tendency, but we were all on the same boat called the Hombu.
I think that learning from every different teacher was a definite strength.
What is it that kept you together through all these years in spite of your parting ways and different practices?
Well,
Back in the 70's,
when Aikido wasn’t as prominent worldwide as today,
there were only one or two people per year that went abroad from the Hombu.
In the 90's however, we started getting requests to send instructors over.
And I think I started to come to France only in the past 15 years or so,
I started in the city of Lyon.
When I first came, Tissier Sensei came all the way to Lyon, and we ate together.
And from that point it happened agian afterwards.
When I was at the Hombu, I was Kisshomaru Sensei’s student first and foremost.
and I stayed there while he was promoting Aikido all over the world.
I think it was 15 years ago that I made it to France and was reunited with Tissier Sensei.
Okamoto Sensei also went to the US at some point to promote Aikido,
before she returned to Japan and taught at her dojo in Kyoto.
There were some French people among us, but I had the honor of being approached by them.
And that led to this friendship.
Hombu obviously has its own protocol and I couldn’t reach out to them myself.
We sometimes talk about the old days, specifically our practice.
I’m not going to drop name, but we were also attracted to the same Sensei.
That’s how we formed this unique relationship, and I’m grateful for that.
What's important is that
in spite of different practices, our basics and the principles are the same.
It's the way we express them and teach people that differs.
What's interesting is to see how our students react.
I look at how my own students react.
When Miyamoto Sensei is in Lyon, or now that he come closer to my home in Puget when he has a bit of time,
my students want to attend.
The young ones, those who do a lot of Aikido, all get in a car and go there.
They are not concerned by our differences, for them, it is Aikido.
What's important is that the basics I gave them...
I often get back to basics, including during this seminar.
Yesterday I tried to do new things, even for me, while today, I showed basics, with an evolution.
If the basics are solid, we can read someone else's Aikido.
We have the keys to understand it.
That way we can see the more subtle aspects of the person.
We don't see it as "another style".
It's the same thing but interpretations can be different.
For Yoko, it's a little bit different
because we have been in permanent contact for a long time.
Every time she teaches in Scotland or in Germany, she comes to Paris if she has time.
We see each other for a day or two,
The ties that unite us are very strong.
I know well her family, her children so it's on a different level.
However, what pleases me is that
when Miyamoto Sensei goes to Argentina,
my Argentinian students go  because that's important for them.
Same when Yoko goes to Brazil or Argentina.
For people, after a point, it doesn't not make any difference.
We are happy to see everybody,
we don't have to go but we go if we want,
but we all belong to the same group.
People follow that group and I think it's great.
Of course I might get to see Miyamoto Sensei or Christian once in a while if I get the chance,
but obviously I don’t see them everyday.
But when I practice, which happens everyday,
I always see something that reminds me of them
like oh, I saw Christian do this, I saw MiyamotoSsensei do this,
he was also doing that at Hombu, so was Yasuno Sensei, and Yamaguchi Sensei and so on.
I see those personalities come out, different shades of Aikido come out all the time.
If I think about it,
I might get to see Miyamoto Sensei only every two months,
Christian once or twice a year,
but they are always in my head, every day.
o they are very close to me in that sense.
That is one thing.
Even if we are physically very distant, I can always feel their presence.
And like Christian just said, I feel happy for my students to go to Miyamoto Sensei or Christian’s class.
I just want them to get the best training possible, including going to the Hombu.
Christian also mentioned this but I believe our role is to show them a variety of Aikido
and also teach them the basic skills so they can adapt to those different styles quickly.
Sorry I guess that was off topic, but anyways, yeah.
[Jordy Delage] It leads to the next question.
Oh the next question, really?
When I go to France, to Lyon, I can see Tissier Sensei’s students.
They take ukemi for me and it is a very good one.
Also, I see Yoko Sensei’s students at the Hombu, and they have a very good ukemi as well.
That assures me that they are receiving really good instruction.
I can tell by their ukemi without seeing their technique.
There are two ways to understand what "good ukemi" means.
Is is someone who know how to take break-falls?
Or is it someone who understand the connection during the movement?
It's important to highlight because who listen to the interview might misunderstand.
Our students who do "good ukemi" are not acrobats.
We want them to be present, fluid...
that they are compressed when they have to...
At same time, this connection must be felt.
I hope that the people who listen to this interview
understand that what we mean by "good ukemi" is not only doing break-falls
but it's how to establish a relationship with the person doing the technique...
[Guillaume Erard] To develop a sort of perception?
Absolutely, yes.
The outer form of your Aikido differs in spite of your common basics. Is it a manifestation of Shuhari?
Well, this Shuhari
Ukemi is a crucial part of practice.
It is the foundation of the technique, and it allows you to learn how to use your body.
Both sensei are doing a great job of teaching them that important aspect.
Hombu teachers like me can’t take direct students.
They are all Doshu Ueshiba Sensei's students.
Of course there is Shuhari
but the teacher who wants to instruct students has to navigate between those three states.
He might have achieved "Ri", the destructuring because he has internalized the principles,
but he must constantly go back to show the kata to the students.
Otherwise, he couldn't go further,
so he must constantly go back to the "Shu" of the construction of the kata.
We have no choice even sometimes we might do something else.
It's a bit of a trap for the teacher.
Sometimes, I don't teach the Aikido I'd like to do myself.
I teach the Aikido that you people need.
So we navigate between those states.
Sometimes, we no longer know where we are.
Sometimes we're a bit confused.
I think it's very important to understand those three states.
I define them as the kata, the form,
then, the kneading of the body, and then getting back to the kata
and when all of this is done, the hips are made, the hands position is right,
the body can express itself,
but we need limits, that's why we need models.
It happened to me in my life as an Aikidoka.
I used to see Yamaguchi Sensei often but he also used to write to me for New Year.
One day, he wrote something to that effect:
"Happy New Year. Be careful, by doing too much sword, you risk to lose the principles."
I thought I wasn't doing a lot of sword to I wondered why he was saying that.
Then I thought that perhaps, my sword work was either too, or not rigid enough,
or perhaps too much based on form, or speed.
So I started to question myself and I deciced to leave the sword as a side thing.
I'm not a kenjutsu teacher, I'm an Aikido teacher.
By doing too much kata, perhaps he feared that my Aikido would become too rigid, I don't know.
So what's interesting is that we can be 6th, 7th, or even 8th Dan, but someone who was our model can still guide us.
"It's OK to go there a bit, but stop, come back a little".
We need that guidance.
We too give guidance to others.
That's our responsibility.
That also our legitimacy to say those things.
We have the legitimacy to say "this is OK, but until today only".
"You do it well until today, but from tomorrow, it must be something else".
"You are going too much in that direction, be careful".
That's why the term "Shihan" has a lot of meaning to me
because you are a model to others, but also to yourself.
A teacher navigates between all those things.
I don't know if you see things that way but I do.
To the question why is everyone still different even if they all receive the same instruction at Hombu,
That’s because everyone has their own personality.
In the context of Japanese tea lessons, we learn how to position our hands
and it must not be different even by a little.
And no matter how much you try to mold them into this, they will always show their personality.
Same with Aikido, regardless of how long we do the same practice,
you will see that person’s character and experiences.
So for me, we are all trying to achieve the same thing, but in different ways.
I’m not Miyamoto Sensei, Christian, Yamaguchi Sensei, Yasuno Sensei or anyone else,
so it’s impossible to do the same.
But how to achieve the same thing with the body that I have?
That’s the question that I have to think about and solve.
We are all different, origin, gender, body structure…
I think that’s why, that’s my answer to the first question.
And also, we talked about uke earlier.
What I think recently is, well Christian said that we have to explain in a way that’s easier for the audience to understand,
and you may think what is a good uke?
A good uke is not about taking an uke.
I think if you expect to take an ukemi, it’s not going to be a good ukemi.
There is tori and uke, and rather than just taking an ukemi,
you have to be able to instantly sense what is going on in the dynamic of the tori and uke through the technique.
I think that’s what a good uke is.
Anyone can take an uke, especially if they’ve been doing Aikido for years,
but for both the uke and tori to learn, you have to go beyond that.
[Christian Tissier] That's right.
That’s so true.
As an instructor, whether you can express what you want,
whether it be your experiences, age, physical strength, and also how you interpret Aikido,
that depends on a good ukemi.
We really get the help of ukemi to express what we want to express.
We see from your answers that terminology is very important. Is it necessary to speak Japanese or to know Japan to become proficient in Aikido?
It doesn’t matter technique-wise,
but when there is a cultural element, it’s better if you can speak the language.
And from what I heard from my seniors who’d always been at Hombu,
the instructors didn’t explain the techniques at all.
You learned by watching, by taking an ukemi.
Your ability to watch, and to copy without words is important regardless of your role.
So the language itself is not that important,
but learning a language is essential in learning about that country’s culture.
You may be able to learn the techniques, but may not go beyond that.
It's always interesting to bring another culture to one's own culture.
I think that people who do Aikido and aren't Japanese are interested in Japanese culture.
They read books and show an interest.
I'm sometimes surprised by how much knowledge people have even though they don't speak Japanese.
When I look here, most people make efforts to speak a bit of Japanese.
Hello, goodbye, and so on.
It's complicated when you teach because there are many elements.
Tamura Sensei used to say "you must steal my techniques".
He meant that you must pay attention.
It's important and one can teach without talking,
but it's important to realize that when you are dealing with people from Japan, Italy, or Sweden,
it's not the same thing.
In Sweden, they don't react the same way as in North Africa in Algeria.
They have their own culture too so as a teacher you can say:
"I'm the boss, you must adapt to my culture",
or you can adapt to what every of them needs.
I don't have the same vocabulary in Serbia for example.
In Serbia, Aikido is quite new, people are strong,
so I don't use the same vocabulary than in Stockholm where the Aikido is softer and more fluid.
Words aren't the same and sometimes, a word can unblock a situation.
To get back to culture, people are very interested in culture,
because Aikido is aimed at people who are already well educated.
But also knowing the language doesn’t mean you know Aikido, so the language is not everything.
I also think it helps to some extent like Christian said.
For example, we didn’t use any translations for this seminar.
And we didn’t for a reason.
We were initially going to.
But there was a sound issue, and also inserting translations really affects the rhythm.
The way the Sensei feel would be different, and the results would be different.
So we decided not to do that half way through.
And if you really wanted to listen to Miyamoto Sensei and Christian, you really had to go in front of them.
Or if you missed a really good point, you could ask them later what they’d said.
We can work around that.
And like Miyamoto Sensei said, the Sensei at Hombu Dojo back then never explained anything.
They say: "stop, this is not good", but never explain why.
All they say is no good. [laughs]
So the question was: "Do you have to learn the language?"
[Jordy Delage] And the culture too.
Well knowing it somewhat helps.
The example I like to use is how Yamaguchi Sensei would always say "Get on".
And that "Get on" (乗る, noru) can be really difficult to translate in French or English.
If you know that noru in Japanese means to ride the wave, let it do what it wants,
it might make more sense to you.
But then again, being able to picture it helps, but that doesn’t mean you can actually do it.
So that’s my take on language.
Thank you very much.
You're welcome, thank you very much.
Thank you.
Thank you very much.